[Music]
all right we're here at the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Sylvia Haas
and I'm Wolfram Alpha on Twitter and I'm
here with my co-host
I'm sure duponte and I was a student at
the wool room my school summer camp this
year
and we're here with John Cougar he's a
CEO he's here to talk about thank you
so yon why are you here at this
conference and what do you do well as
said I am the CEO of or from a math core
and we are developing a tool called
system offer which is a tool to model
all sorts of systems it could be the
human heart or it could be a gas turbine
or it could be an ecological system so
all sorts of things and I'm here at the
conference to show the new stuff that we
have been developing during the year my
project am I'm leading in the group as I
said so there are several different
projects this year we worked on things
like adding new libraries so you can use
the software for new applications it's
to be a bit technical this is
synchronous systems it's working with
fluid systems and then we also added
we're adding integration with machine
learning from machine learning part of
Mathematica into our system models and
also working on integration with a cloud
so as Wolfman 1 for instance
can we see an example that so let me see
are gonna have to do something or do you
have it on screen yeah yeah I can just
go here this is this is the hello world
of system over let me do this I can make
it co2 up it so I can do things so it's
a and so you can see two here yeah so
this is is our hollow world
it's a DC motor I don't know any about
your background but basically we have
some electrical circuits here like a
resistor and we have a shaft built by by
an inertia so if I behind the scenes
behind these things here that I can sort
of drag around and I can connect them as
I want there are equations so do you
happen to know which equation governs
the resistor its Ohm's law so which is
basic saying a relationship with the
current and voltage and the resistance
in in the resistor most components in
the world can be described by some sort
of equations and when you combine these
equations you get a whole system that
you sent then can run and in this case
simulate so if I click here simulate for
this guy here what it does it sort of
takes this graphical representation and
makes a code for it that is compiled and
afterwards we can simulate for some
business taking a bit of time and here
we have let's change which easier to see
so what we're looking here is when we're
feeding this DC motor with a constant
signal in how fast will this shaft
accelerate an idea with system owner is
to see what happens if I do a design
change for instance I have a heavier
shaft or another resistor
I could come up with a change say both
the parameters here and say okay let's
let's change the the inertia here to
something bigger it's one kilogram per
meter squared and I'll change that to
ten if I make a head and a heavier shaft
on there on a DC motor would you imagine
it going faster or slower so let's let's
then simulate that and see what happens
yeah so you'll see it sort of has a
slower dynamic so this is all what is
all about you have sort of a leg of
thing where you cool things together and
it could be something like this DC motor
or as I said it could become a model of
a human heart or whatever you're doing
and then you play around changing the
parameters and change these things in
the model to understand what's actually
going on with your system and how we can
optimize it so who are you envisioning
using this it's a good question it's an
easy and hard question because there is
so many different people that can use it
you can use it for education for
instance to in many cases what you're
doing in education you learn a lot of
equations or you learn these specific
things but you don't put them into
context because you can't run a gas
turbine for instance you don't have
access to real gas turbine so you
learned some equation about it and then
you suppose to understand how the whole
thing works together right but if you
have a model then you can put that
equation into some sort of context play
around and get some more understanding
of how it works so that's a typical
scenario even though advanced example
here of how you would use it as a
student as a researcher you might take
that in order to see what happens if I
change the design of my gas turbine here
and test different things and as as the
industry using the same thing I might
want to optimize how fast I can start my
gas turbine what happens if we have
some electricity car we might have
lightning for instance and then perhaps
something happens with our electrical
grid
how will that affect our our gas turbine
or whatever sort of turbine ha will it
still run as as we would want it to or
will it fail can I test paint strategies
to make it run more say run run safely
and be more robust so it has
applications all sorts of levels so what
are the future plans for this project so
yeah there's several different things
here where should I start I have my
presentation tomorrow I realized that my
presentation there way too much for me
to be able to present it during one year
in half an hour
so I decided that I'll solve that during
the presentation tomorrow some way but
we can so I actually use this one to
illustrate the presentation what we're
doing so in Sweden we actually eat more
candy than anywhere else in the world
and that it happened back in the days
that they decided to introduce something
called las ruedas Saturday candy amazing
yeah and the idea was that that kid
should only eat on Saturdays so we
should eat less candy the consequence
became the other that all kids expect to
have cameo Saturdays of course but it
still want candy other days of the week
so so now we are the biggest consumer of
candy and do you typically eat them like
this this is from my store back home
took a picture this is at the exit at
the entrance issue is one other section
like this
like and this is what you see in every
single story we won't go into is the
candy first in the candy last and then
all sorts of shapes forms tastes and so
on and that's sort of what what the next
system over is also there's so many
different things there are things that
is the sugar is the salt is is the sour
it's the gel of the green and so on so
it's all sort of things and then taking
one of these is sort of hard let's see
what yeah so one of those things would
be synchronous library and they makes a
bit more visual if I if I show it here
let's see if I have this is my libraries
for my presentation tomorrow my glasses
on my lenses they're not too good for
for this distance they go so this in a
sense is similar to these motor that we
have different components but it happens
to be some sort of tank with a mixer
where we are on mixing some some liquid
and we want to control that using
something called inverse control so we
have the mixer here again but but
working in the other direction so these
try to try to predict what's going to
happen in the future depending on what
actions we take and in that way give us
the optimal way to accomplish whatever
we want accomplish get it set
temperature and so on so what we've
added for what we added now with
something called synchronous which makes
it possible to do things that are
clocked meaning that rather then then
being continuous as much of the things
are in real life right now if I throw
something it's it won't just jump from
one place another it passes all the way
through synchronous happens at specific
clocked instances you have a value in
between there's nothing really going on
by setting these sort of sampler here
and here anything inside that will be
treated as something happen in
synchronous if I simulate that as
probably bit more apparent what what
what happens so yet again it compiles
this code so this is probably one of the
sour candies for whoever is in theory in
a technical field right
I love somewhere sour candy so this now
we now we see here with a is on purpose
quite bad controller so this is what we
want to achieve and this is what we are
actually achieved and if i zoom in we
can see that this one is continuous but
this one has all all has values in
points and that's sort of one of the
things where it so it automatically even
if this system was defined as a
continuous system by yes clocking it
everything is is handle automatically to
treat it as a clock system so for anyone
in this field with sort of a really
important thing and for anyone else it's
a it's a sour candy that it might not
appreciate and that's sort of how the
whole thing is that's a lot of something
for everyone to something for everyone
did you have anything else that you
would like to add it's hard because I
could add either here was lumping I'm
almost a bit about customers and what
they actually using it for yeah so you
mentioned that you had done something on
malaria so I thought you might be
interested in
does this come out as expected do you
see my screen here you see yes so this
this is just one example where system
over has has been used so when you do
live when you have problem with your
liver what you do is take your liver
biopsy so take a small sample of your
liver
apparently that hurts a lot and not only
when they do it but afterwards inside so
you want to avoid it and it's not very
precise because your liver is sort of
it's like an orange
has different segments one segment could
be perfectly fine and the rest bad and
you take that sound sample wrap randomly
perhaps to take this from the good one
and then the rest is bad and it hurt a
lot when doing the diagnosis and you got
something in wrong incorrect answer so
in this project what they did is
developed a model system over that
replicates what would happen if you have
a good or bad liver what will happen
with the specific substance with you if
you swallow that how should that sort of
be transported from one organ to another
in the body so how does it go through
the liver for instance so the kidney and
so on and then instead of taking a
biopsy you send in a person into an MRI
scan where they look at how that take
pictures over time like an hour that's
what you see here and get samples of how
the level of this substance changes in
the liver over time and then you can you
can correlate that to two models of the
health deliver this is River and so on
and in that way understand if it's the
condition of the middle so that is for
me is a very cool application of where
you use a system and as you see it's
something done with Lynch Epis
University and an SSN account thank you
so much for coming in and talking with
us today thank you
[Music]